continúa la información de américa
latina y el mundo aquí en plan 24 vamos
a hablar ahora de economía y estamos
para eso con maryna hablando nada ni la
bienvenida nuevamente y empezamos
hablando de eeuu porque el país que
opone un mínimo un impuesto mínimo
global a las multinacionales o la
liliana pues comencemos por recordar que
una de las propuestas de campaña de joe
biden fue justamente subir el impuesto
corporativo del 21 al 28 por ciento
antes era del 35 por ciento pero el
presidente el expresidente donald trump
lo bajó en 2017 este lunes en la
secretaría del tesoro janet yellen
aseguró que trabajará con otras
economías avanzadas del g20 para
establecer un impuesto mínimo
corporativo esto lo hace justo un día
antes de que inicie la reunión de
primavera del banco mundial y del fondo
monetario internacional
kinect y como otra consecuencia de un
mundo interconectado ha sido una carrera
de 30 años a la baja en las tasas de
impuestos corporativos
making víctor fermentos 'estable' text
se trata de asegurarse de que los
gobiernos tengan sistemas tributarios
estables
que generen ingresos suficientes para
invertir en bienes públicos esenciales y
responder a las crisis y que todos los
ciudadanos compartan de manera justa la
carga de financiar el gobierno en un
crowdfunding liliana esta es una
propuesta que ya lleva años
discutiéndose en el seno de la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico que también se
conoce como el club de países ricos pero
por el momento no ha tenido éxito
daniela y casi la mitad de los lugares
argentinos se endeudaron para afrontar
la pandemia si liliana el instituto
nacional de estadística y censos realizó
un segundo estudio sobre el impacto de
la pandemia en los bolsillos de los
ciudadanos en esta ocasión detectó que 4
de cada 10 hogares en el área más
poblada del país tuvieron que endeudarse
para hacerle frente a la crisis el 53
por ciento dijo que tuvo problemas
laborales o redujo su ingreso y un 70
por ciento tomó alguna medida económica
al interior de su hogar por ejemplo
recurrir a los ahorros personales o
vender algunas de sus pertenencias el
estudio se hizo en buenos aires y su
cordón urbano en donde reside una
tercera parte de los 45 millones de
habitantes que tiene este
danielle y las remesas en méxico
alcanzaron un nuevo récord pues liliana
cuando comenzó la pandemia a uno de los
principales temores era que los países
que dependen en gran medida de los
envíos de sus familiares en el exterior
iban a recibir menos divisas por ese
concepto pero ha ocurrido exactamente lo
contrario uno de los ejemplos es méxico
entre enero y febrero llegaron a este
país casi 6.500 millones de dólares esto
es un 20 por ciento más que el mismo
período del año pasado sólo en febrero
se recibieron más de 3 mil millones de
dólares esta es una cifra récord para
este mes desde que iniciaron los
registros en 1995 la mayoría de las
remesas hacia ese país recordemos
provienen de eeuu
daniela y google le ganó una millonaria
pelea ahora con y pues este es un tema
un poquito técnico pero vamos a tratar
de explicarlo mire el gigante
tecnológico google desarrolló en 2007 el
software del sistema operativo de
android que es uno de los más usados en
el mundo para hacerlo utilizó partes del
lenguaje de programación denominado java
que había sido creado por una empresa
adquirida
que se llama sun microsystems para
desarrollar este sistema oracle dice que
google usó unas 11.500 líneas de su
código java y que esto violaba las leyes
sobre derechos de autor la pelea
jurídica se remonta a 2010 cuando oracle
demandó a google y pidió una
compensación cercana a los 8 mil
millones de dólares después de 11 años
de litigio el tribunal supremo de eeuu
le dio la razón en última instancia
google que siempre alegó que esta es una
práctica muy común en la industria y que
el iava es un código de computación
puramente funcional pero no creativo
bueno daniela y vamos a ver ahora los
indicadores de la jornada
liliana el viernes se conoció que eeuu
creó casi un millón de empleos en marzo
y esto impulsó a wall street' dos de sus
principales índices
el estándar han puesto y el dow jones de
industriales cerraron en récord y en
europa la mayoría de las bolsas no pero
por ser día festivo pero si lo hicieron
en américa latina donde hubo buenos
impulsos en méxico brasil y argentina- y
terminamos con la cita del día 48,5
millones de dólares
esa fue la taquilla en eeuu y canadá de
la película
godzilla versus kong desde su estreno el
miércoles en semana santa en más de 3000
salas de cine con esto ha logrado el
mejor estreno de una película durante la
pandemia es daniela por la información
de economía y ustedes por estar entrados
24 quédense con nosotros para más de la
información que hemos preparado con este
equipo periodístico
[Música]